Hi.
Everybody hear me okay?
Yes?
Awesome.
So I'm a web developer at
Mozilla, I'm the lead engineer on the Webmaker
for Android project, and I want
to start off on a high note here.
The web is broken.
And I don't mean the
Wi-Fi.
Although the Wi-Fi is totally broken right
now.
So I'm not going to
demo some of the stuff I was going to show
you.
But that's okay.
It's not
actually broken for most of you JavaScript
developers, right?
On Firefox and
Chrome and Edge, for you, the web is probably
still pretty awesome.
But for
the rest of the world coming online right
now, and that's like 2 billion
people over the next few years, it really
kind of sucks.
And that's just
because for more and more people, the first
and only experience they're ever
going to have of the web is mobile.
And the mobile web is not good enough.
So
let's talk about why the mobile web is not
good enough.
You probably know most
of this already.
The one that you are probably feeling a lot
right now is UI
perf.
Particularly when you're doing things like
gestures and lots of layout
panes -- not great.
Not as good as we'd like.
But there's lots of other things
that are broken.
The auth model that's based on email doesn't
make any sense
for new users of the web who don't even have
emails.
The experience when you
go offline or you're on a 3G or less connection
is really pretty terrible for
most of the web.
And of course, all of the access to the OS
level device
integrations, like push notifications, and
camera.
And on the one hand, that's
okay.
The web was built for a completely different
desktop-based paradigm,
right?
And it's going to take some time for browsers
to work on solutions.
Right?
That's fine.
But on the other hand, it's kind of not okay,
because not
only does the web kind of suck at all these
things right now, native platforms
are actually really good at them.
And there's some technical reasons why
performance and other things are easy to get
right on native platforms.
But
the thing with native is it was built with
these problems at the center of its
business model, and the web was not.
So I was actually kind of wondering --
you know, is this still something that people
care about?
Are we still talking
about this?
And it turns out it is.
Just yesterday, actually, one of the
leading authorities on browser quirks and
compatibility since the '90s, I
think -- he wrote an article on his blog,
and it was called web versus native.
Let's concede defeat.
I want to read this out, because it's important.
I feel
like it's time to revisit the web versus native
debate and concede defeat,
that the web should not and cannot compete
with native when it comes to
complex app-like structures.
His argument essentially is that because of
the
fundamental architectural limitations of how
the web was built, we're just
going to have to give up on building these
rich client app-like experiences
and go back to the true strengths of the web,
which is URLs, universal
accessibility, et cetera.
And you know what?
He has a point.
You know,
overlooking the fact that there's a few things
like offline that still affects
the overall interoperability of the web, this
is a totally reasonable,
rational argument, when you look at the current
state of affairs.
And it might
actually even be a popular one.
Honestly, if what you really want to do right
now today is to build the fastest, coolest,
most awesome UI, with 3D and games
and whatever, I would have to tell you -- you
know what?
You should consider
building for Android or iOS.
But if what we're saying -- that this is the
way
to fix the mobile web, it's to give up and
abandon app-like experiences for
something that, you know, works better with
our original model of the web, I
couldn't disagree more.
But to do that, first, I want to take a look
back at the year 2004.
How many
of you were doing web development back in
2004?
Wow.
That's a lot of you.
This
is awesome.
So you're totally going to remember some of
the stuff I'm going to
talk about here.
So...
Yeah, I was a big fan, actually, of both Britney
Spears
and Orlando Bloom.
According to Google's zeitgeist of the year,
they were the
two most popular people.
The top two tech topics, according to Google
analytics, number one was wallpaper.
Number two was Kazaa.
Yeah.
If we were
doing JSConf in 2004, that's what we would
be talking about.
Pretty awesome.
So also -- PHP5 was released that year, Ruby
on Rails was at 0.5.0, and Google
had been around for about six years already.
So that's cool.
So something else
happened in 2004.
It was the year -- actually, it was the year
that Facebook
was released as well.
Although I don't actually remember that.
But it was
actually the year that Google first released
Gmail.
And at first, because it
was released in April and Google had this
reputation for being notorious for
April fool's jokes, people thought it was
maybe a joke.
Does anybody remember
when Gmail came out?
Were you signed up for Gmail?
Yeah.
I don't remember it
being as cool as people said it was.
But it was...
I guess was pretty cool.
It
was a real thing, and it was cool for two
reasons.
Okay?
One was that it
offered a gig of storage.
Where all the other online competitors like
Hotmail
and Yahoo offered way less than that, and
the second thing was that Gmail had
this super neat interface that could actually
live update when you received a
new email, without requiring a page refresh.
That was super awesome, right?
And in 2004, the idea of re-rendering the
DOM with new data, after the page had
loaded, so like...
AJAX, was not at all common on the web, nor
was it even
expected.
All the other web email clients were terrible
and clunky and
required lots of page refreshes, but that
was just the way things were.
If you
wanted an app-like experience, you were expected
to use a Windows email
client.
Right?
Pretty reasonable.
So when the lead developer of Gmail told his
co-workers he was going to write the entire
app totally in the browser and
almost entirely in JavaScript, they were like...
What?
Really?
You know, in
fact, almost everybody he talked to, even
internally at Google, especially
people who considered themselves to be experts
at JavaScript and the web,
thought his idea was totally naive, it was
never going to work, because people
had tried to write complex things in JavaScript
before, and they knew the web
was just not made to do that kind of stuff.
And this was a really common
opinion at the time.
JavaScript was at best a thing that...
You know, could
decorate your pages or enhance them a little
bit, and at worst, it was a
security flaw, it was non-standards compliant,
it was disruptive and pretty
terrible, right?
So I want to show you some things that people
were actually
writing.
I was digging back into the Wayback Machine
and some old blogs circa
2004.
This was from the anti-JavaScript FAQ.
While I am personally opposed to
all JavaScript, I understand it can do some
things that you can't do with
normal html.
But just remember -- if Amazon can do without
JavaScript, so can
you.
So this was from a post titled JavaScript
is evil.
A lot of designers
think it's their god-given right to annoy
the hell out of visitors with bulky
JavaScript effects, so turning off JavaScript
is almost a requirement when
visiting some websites.
It was true at the time.
This is from stupid
JavaScript security tricks.
A little bit older, but still relevant.
Blindly
accepting a high level of security risk on
the web by enabling JavaScript is
as shaky as a ride on the Canadian space shuttle
made of birch bark and gum.
I'm Canadian, so this really resonated with
me.
Woo, represent.
So this is
what people were saying.
JavaScript was not a thing.
But despite the fact that
it took years for Gmail to...
Whoops.
Uh-oh.
My computer died.
I'm going to
have to plug in.
Okay.
I don't need internet.
But...
Sorry about that.
So...
Computers fail sometimes.
Not only is the mobile web broken.
Batteries are
broken too.
Yeah.
Oh, thanks.
You're the best.
See?
Community.
This is what
makes JavaScript better.
All right.
Let's boot up.
Sorry.
It was the Gmail
curse, honestly.
(Never Going to Give You Up playing)
Oh, gosh.
All right, we're booting, we're booting.
I'm really sorry.
Phones
were super different?
Phones were super different in the '80s than
they are today.
Yeah, they were.
In the '80s, I had Jenny's number, and now
I have 8675309 apps on my phone.
It's true.
It was really different back in the 2000s
too -- people assumed
email could only be done native.
But we're about to find out why...
Yeah, it's
just going to take a minute.
Okay.
Should have plugged in.
Yeah, it's true.
Oh, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Sorry, sorry.
All right.
We're back.
Let's hear it for the hibernate feature on
computers, everybody.
As opposed
to rebooting from scratch.
(Never Going to Give You Up playing)
We're back.
No, we're not back.
Now...
Which one was the right one?
Probably this one.
Let's find out.
Yes!
Okay!
So...
We're back.
We're back in
the immersive interactive web.
Awesome.
Still in 2004.
So despite all of this
weird stuff, and the fact that JavaScript
was terrible, and it was a total
hack, Gmail was a total hack, it was living
proof that you could write
something in JavaScript that people actually
loved.
And that's awesome.
And,
you know, it wasn't long after this that developers
started getting excited
about the XML-HTTP thing and using it all
over the place, and before we knew
it, great rich client experiences became something
that was essential to the
web, as the promise of interoperability itself.
Fast-forward to 2006, and all
of a sudden XML-HTTP thing has now been standardized
by the W3C, and
JavaScript is moving towards the process of
standardization and universal
acceptance.
Hurray!
Clap for JavaScript!
So the point is this: you're not here
at this conference about to learn about knitting
and making music and driving
robots because someone intended or designed
to make JavaScript or the web to
do these things.
You're not here because of the standards body.
You're not
even here because of a browser.
Well, you're kind of here because of a
browser.
But not entirely because of a browser.
You're here because someone
wanted to do something cool and found a super
hacky but somewhat compelling
way to make it happen.
So my proposal to fix the mobile web is this:
stop
relying on browsers to reimplement the DOM
or land device APIs or do whatever
it is you want.
Stop thinking about what the web is or what
the web was.
Maybe
this is totally naive, but I don't think that
rich app-like experiences are
something we're going to be able to pass over,
no matter how compelling and
awesome the URL is.
And if you want to talk to me about URLs,
I will talk you
to about URLs.
If you want to be here, talking about JavaScript,
in five
years, it's time to hack.
So in order to demonstrate some of the ways
you
might do this today, I would like to use a
model I've devised called the three
levels of hack.
Where we start in a place that most people
would kind of agree
is not that weird, and then end up with something
that's really weird.
So
start small.
First level of hack.
Test new features before their time.
That's
a great way to push the platform a little
bit.
To use new browser language
features, right?
That haven't made it into production.
So one way to do that
is to turn on stuff that's there and use it.
Easy, right?
One thing I'm
personally really excited about is the service
worker -- which is going to
help out with offline in a huge way.
And I'm not going to talk about it in
detail, but if you've ever used AppCache or
are thinking about taking your app
online, you should definitely check it out.
There's already an implementation.
Chrome, you can check it out today, and I
think the Firefox implementation is
coming out in the summer sometime.
So that's super cool.
You can also polyfill
the features that you want to make them work
for features today.
One of the
things we do on my team is transpile ES6 using
Babel.
And Sebastian is
speaking about that later this afternoon.
So I highly recommend you attend
that session.
And doing this kind of stuff is not controversial.
But I'm
mentioning it because if you're not doing
it, you should.
And the other thing
you should do is -- if you find bugs, or you
have opinions about how things
should be changed, you know, the implementation
teams that are building them
really want to hear from you.
The Gecko team, for example, working really
hard
on service workers right now, is really interested
on getting feedback on the
service worker and how you want to use it.
So if you're interested in joining
that conversation, just talk to me after and
I can hook you up with the right
people.
Okay.
So let's do the second level of hack.
Building new abstractions.
So beyond things that are being implemented
-- cool
stuff really comes out of people thinking
in completely different ways with
the tools that are there.
So, you know, one area we're seeing a lot
of
innovation -- I'm sure all of you are aware,
probably using this stuff -- is
DOM abstractions, like Reacts, virtual DOM,
famous engines DOM and web GL
abstraction, flip board did a cool thing with
react and canvas.
For the most
part, they don't replace the DOM.
They augment and reoptimize particular areas
of it by building an abstraction, and that's
pretty cool.
It's a total hack.
Let's be honest.
But it's awesome.
Another thing you can do with abstractions
is build things that already exist, but don't
yet exist -- have a counterpart
on the web.
So going back to the offline use case, a pretty
cool example I've
seen in the last few months is some colleagues
of mine have been working on
something called Filer, which is basically
a POSIX compliant file system
interface in the browser.
It doesn't actually use a file system.
It just
abstracts one on top of index DB or web SQL
or even in memory.
So that means
that any modern browser who has access to
those things can actually do file
operations and store them offline, which is
amazing.
There's a group of super
smart people working on a code editor that
takes advantage of Filer at Seneca
College in Toronto, so you should check that
out if you're interested in
Filer.
It's super cool.
So...
Okay.
We talked about some fairly...
You know, things that are exciting.
But not exactly controversial.
Because we're still building on top of existing
APIs, and mostly doing things in a web-like
way.
But what if we could go
actually further than that?
You know, if the browser is the thing that
holds
you back, why not just hack on that?
Cool, right?
And in this case, I'm not
talking about, like, submitting a patch to
Firefox for Android, although if
you would like to do that, there's a link.
You know, totally awesome.
You
totally can and should.
What I'm talking about is basically hacking
together
your own user agent inside of a native environment.
And this is also known as
hybrid app development.
Right?
And maybe you haven't heard hybrid app
development described quite like that.
Hacking together your own user agent.
That's essentially what it is.
And there's some frameworks out there that
can
take care of the dirtiest part of that hack.
If you want to try them out, I
would highly recommend Cordova, which is a
really brilliant project that feels
the closest to actually still developing with
the web, but getting APIs from
the native device.
But I do actually think it's valuable to do
yourself.
You
know, are you going to implement a better
browser for all mobile users?
You
know, are you smarter than the people who
work on Firefox and Chrome, and
Windows?
Absolutely not.
You're not.
I'm sorry.
Maybe you are.
I don't know.
Come work for us if you are.
But you're probably not.
But...
You know,
personally, for what I'm working on...
No, seriously.
Come talk to me.
For
what I'm working on, I found that building
a custom hybrid architecture, while
it's not the solution for all of the web's
problems, it allowed me to
experiment with solving the exact problems
that we were having with the mobile
web, and understanding that connection much
better than I would, you know,
using something like Cordova, or just building
within the browser.
So to put
this into perspective, I'm going to talk a
little bit about what my team at
Mozilla is working on.
We're interested in what web authoring tools
might look
like, primarily for new users of the web in
Bangladesh, Brazil, India, and
Kenya, using only a mobile phone.
So that's, like, what our problem is.
And the first iteration we experimented with
was a client side single page
app.
We didn't target iOS, because it's not a huge
part of our market.
But we
had specific issues that were major blockers.
Obviously we needed to make
something work really, really well offline,
and in 3G or less.
That was a huge
requirement for us.
We tried using AppCache, but it wasn't doing
what we
needed it to do.
We were seeing a lot of issues with memory
leaks popping up
in client side memory architectures, particularly
when building or destroying
new views.
Especially when people are idling the apps
on their phone for three
or four hours.
That was a huge issue for us.
Another big issue was UI perf.
It's an editing interface when you touch.
And 50% of our user were still using
Android phones before 4.4.
Anybody develop for the stock Android browser?
Nobody?
Oh my goodness.
You think IE is bad.
You should try developing for the
Android soft browser.
It does not autoupdate.
It's pretty horrible.
So these
were problems.
Let's figure out how we fix some of these
things in a custom Android
environment.
So...
Actually, any Android developers here?
No?
Oh, we've got
one.
This is good.
All right.
This is going to be interesting to
you.
So I was going to skip past this part.
If you guys all do Android.
But...
All right.
So the basic architecture -- how do we build
this custom hybrid
app?
And by the way, this is really similar to
how Cordova works or any other
hybrid architecture.
I want you to understand how you do it yourself.
So the
first thing we do is we start with an Android
activity, which is like a basic
view in Android.
And that may or may not contain some UI, like
a back button
or a header.
Or it might just be like a frame to hold the
web view.
All right?
So how do we do that?
We write some Java.
We create an activity.
We create the
layout in XML.
Then we add it to the manifest, where we can
specify things
like the name and the parent view, the view
hierarchy, stuff like that.
It's
kind of weird, but not so weird.
Inside that, we instantiate a web runtime.
That can be Chromium or even Gecko.
There's a project to do that, but it's not
ready yet.
That's super cool.
And Android makes it easy to do.
In 4.4 plus or
web kit -- you just implement the class instantiate.
Super easies, right?
Like
us, you probably want to support the most
modern version of browsers.
Instead
of using the built in Webkit, you can use
this, which is crosswalk.
Lets you
embed the latest version of Android as far
back as 4.0.
And it exposes the
same JavaScript Java bindings -- it's great.
Crosswalk project.org.
So the
last thing we're going to need in this architecture
is a communication layer
that binds our JavaScript and our Android
code together.
Some of that is
provided by the web view class or the crosswalk
class, so you can load
external URLs, you can load packaged assets
inside your app.
And if you're
wondering -- yes, even if you're using the
file protocol, you can do XHR,
because this is your own user agent, and you
can do what you want.
All right.
But the real magic that happens, though, is
you can expose a custom
Java interface into your JavaScript by attaching
it to the window object, and
that kind of lets you do whatever you want.
So what does that look like?
We've
got -- we add JavaScript interface to our
web view, we basically attach a
class to it, and we can add some methods on
that class.
And those methods that
are declared actually show up on window.Android,
or whatever -- we can call it
whatever we want.
I called it Android.
We can just call those Java functions.
Of course, you're fairly limited in what kind
of data structures you can pass
through.
You're going to want to use primitives like
strings and stuff.
You
can't pass full objects or functions around.
Sorry.
But...
It's still pretty
powerful.
And that's basically it.
So...
Yeah.
That's how it works.
If you remember from
our example, one of the major issues we had
was that the client side routing
caused a lot of unexpected memory leaks.
Long lived processes were kind of not
so great in our client side app.
So what we did -- and this is something you
couldn't do in Cordova, but we could, because
we were hacking something
together -- in order to fix the issue we had,
we actually moved the routing
into Android, so we could take advantage of
the more sophisticated memory
management and life cycle events, and we instantiated
each page of the app as
an isolated view with its own activity.
That's really similar to server side
routing, and it actually has the same benefits,
like encapsulation of each
page, but in Android, we also get the added
benefit of super smooth
transitions, layout hierarchies, we can get
the back button to do what we
want, so we get the best of both worlds.
Pretty cool.
What did we do about
shared state?
This is where the JS Java bindings come in.
Because we're using
React to render the web UI, it's pretty trivial
to send parameters into React
and take the state out of React and cache
in Android.
So what does passing
rooted params look like?
You stringify the router params, get an initial
state
function, and all of a sudden you have all
the information from your router.
That's pretty simple.
And to cache state, we create a JavaScript
interface
called setState, that allows us to pass in
a stringified JSON object, so it
can be cached in the shared preferences in
Android.
And our React code, we
just need to hook into it.
So every time our component updates, we set
the
state in Android, so it's cached, and when
the component mounts, we just pull
it down and then restore the state.
So super simple.
But it solves a problem
-- we can restore things in an offline context,
we can get around using that
Android-based routing, without having to sacrifice
our User Experience.
So
what about device integration?
This is something actually if you're going
to
do it, you should look at the Cordova code
base.
There's a lot of things that
looked at device integration.
Here we write some of the typical code you
would
write in an Android app for dispatching the
camera intent, looking at whether
you want a camera or gallery, we create a
URI out of our image, or we could do
something like upload it at that point in
time.
And then we actually post it
in this super awesome hacky JavaScript window
thing.
We actually post it to a method in JavaScript,
we post the URI, and then all
of a sudden we can use it in our JavaScript.
So it seems totally terrible, but
hey -- you get an understanding of how Android
is receiving the camera intent.
You get an understanding of what you can do
in terms of compression.
You get
to be a lot closer to your device than you
ever would be using some web API or
just saying...
Well, we can't support camera.
So what else?
There's lots of
things you can do.
You can bind to Android's offline network
caching
utilities.
You know, if you want to do that -- before
service workers are
available.
You can hook into some native gestures, so
you could actually read
gestures on the Android side and post them
into JavaScript.
If you want to do
things like pinch zooms or swipes that are
much better architected in the
Android platform.
And of course, you can do lots of device integration,
like
push notifications or whatever you want.
And really, it's up to you.
Because
it's your browser.
Well, it's your user agent.
So...
The truth is I'm not really sure any of this
is going to be actually
successful.
Or even that it's reasonable or possible to
make fundamental
changes to the mobile web in this way that
works.
But what I am certain of is
if you don't try bold, native things -- naive
things, and develop a better
understanding of the platform you're building
for, you know, if all you're
doing is pushing up against the edges of the
browser, things are not going to
change.
No one is going to fix the web but you, and
your understanding of your
real problems.
So I want to end with something inspired by
my dad.
This is my
dad.
Because one, he was pretty much the coolest
engineer I've ever met in my
life.
And two, because Friday would have been his
71st birthday.
So happy
birthday, dad.
Thanks.
So my dad was totally self-taught.
He was an amateur
radio hacker, and he also designed some really,
really cool radical
electronics equipment back in the '60s, '70s,
and '80s.
He worked with a lot
of people who had engineering degrees, and
one of the things he said all the
time was -- for all their education and understanding
of theory, a lot of
people just didn't really get what good engineering
was.
Good engineering.
Because to my dad, really good engineering
was finding adequate solutions to
problems that really matter to people.
In a way that someone in the future,
who's smarter and better than you can understand
and improve on.
And as long
as you're okay with the fact that the web
is always going to be this
patchwork, open, weird, somewhat hacky, totally
imperfect thing, as long as
you're willing to think about it and build
for the real world around you, and
not for what the platform tells you to do,
you're probably going to make
something great.
You know, for the 500 things that suck and
are terrible,
you're going to make something great.
And if the talks we have lined up...
You
know, in the next few days, are any indication
of what people think about
that, I think we're going to be fine.
So hack the good hack, my friends.
Thank
you very much.